Nice to meet you.
I'm a witch. You're a witch. You're a witch. You're an
extinct witch. It's not like humans are talking about witches. In
fact, we lived a witch hunt. If so, then why didn't you
come to Chloe's rescue?
Why, friends?
I'm sorry for leaving everyone to die.
Even if I apologize, Kue will be
back. I'll bring him back to life.
Don't insult us any more if you bring him back to life. Listen, Adonis. I'm here to
save you, this country.  Everything that has infiltrated Black is black. I
need you and her memory to revive her. I need you to bring her back to life.
[Music] I'll kill
anyone who gets in my way. I'll kill anyone who opposes me. I'll
kill anyone who laughs at black. Black.  I'll kill anyone who talks about it. I'll kill everyone. If it makes
you feel better, then I
'm glad.
[Music]
Nis, come back to life.
Come with me, you won't be alone anymore.
[Applause]
Adonis